I think people don't understand the coal
power plants because of their emissions
they cause a certain number of deaths
every year far more dangerous than
nuclear power plants I would say this is
a national security risk it's not listen
play time is over okay obviously play
time is over it's a national security
rights to shut these things down we've
essentially designed civilization to be
super sensitive to climate change the
important thing to appreciate is that we
are going to exit the fossil fuels era
it is inevitable that we will exit the
phosphorylation era because at a certain
point we'll simply run out of uh carbon
to mine and Bone the question is really
when do we exit the error not if the
goal is to exit the error as
quickly as possible given that oil and
even coal are a finite resource it
doesn't seem to make sense that we would
run that experiment when we have to get
off them anyway because they're simply
finite very terrible situation but he
also said it's not like there's no good
that comes out of even a terrible
situation there's some good that comes
out of it but it's overwhelmingly bad
it's just really interesting to read
about history learn the lessons of
History such that we do not repeat
mistakes of the past that means we need
to move from the old goal with the
pre-industrial girl goal which was to
move from chopping down forests and
killing lots of whales
that the old goal was to move from
chopping wood and
and killing whales to fossil fuels which
is actually in that context was a good
thing but the new goal is to move to a
sustainable energy future and we want to
use things like Hydro solar wind
geothermal nuclear is also a good option
in places like France which don't aren't
subject to natural disasters and we want
to use energy sources that will be good
for for a billion years so you need a
solar batteries it will be the main
long-term way that Civilization is
powered but between now and then we need
to maintain nuclear I can't emphasize
enough please do not shut down the
nuclear power plants and please reopen
the ones that have been chat this is
total Madness to shut them down I want
to be clear and I think we just want to
take the set of actions that accelerate
the transition to a sustainable energy
economy and that sustainable energy
economy is going to be like I said
primarily solo with wind you absolutely
need stationary storage batteries
because of the intermittency of solar
and wind and then then there will also
be hydroelectric a geothermal nuclear
these are all fine and the common but we
want to just move as quickly as we can
to a sort of a solar electric economy
and sometimes people say oh it's cloudy
or something what about solar and do
plants grow there are solar powered
chemical reaction If plants grow you
have solar power obviously why do you
think they grow so there's a certain
amount of carbon that is circulating
through the environment so it's going
into the air being absorbed by an ending
getting absorbed by plants and animals
and then going back into the air and
this this carbon is just circulating on
the surface and this this is fine and
it's been doing that for hundreds of
millions of years the thing that's
changed is that we've added something to
the mix billions of tons of carbon
that's been buried for hundreds of
millions of years and is not part of the
carbon cycle taking from deep
underground and adding it to the carbon
cycle carbon parts per million has
really been bouncing around the 300
level for around 10 million years and
then the last few hundred years it went
into a vertical climb this this is the
the essence of the problem this is very
unusual
um and a very very extreme threat as you
can see from this rate of growth then
this is accompanied by a temperature
increase as one would expect I like to I
believe in the scientific method and one
should be one should have a healthy
skepticism of things in general and what
do you think the percentage chance is of
of this being catastrophic for some
meaningful percentage of the Earth's
population
um is it greater than one percent is it
even one percent
um if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment we're playing
Russian roulette and as each year goes
by we're loading more rounds in the
chamber
it's not wise small changes result in
huge effects the sensitivity of the
climate is extremely extremely high you
know what we're doing right now which is
Mining and burning trillions of tons of
hydrocarbons that used to be buried very
deep underground and now we're sticking
them in the atmosphere and running this
crazy chemical experiment on the
atmosphere and then you've got the oil
and gas companies which have ungodly
amounts of money and you can't expect
them to just roll over and die like they
don't do that but the momentum towards
sustainable energy is too slow there's a
vast base of Industry
vast transportation system like this two
and a half billion cars and trucks in
the world the new car and truck
production if it was a hundred percent
electric that's only about 100 million
per year so it would take if you could
snap your fingers
and instantly turn all cars and trucks
electric it would still take 25 years to
change the transport base to Electric
well the thing that is going on right
now is that there's a an inherent
subsidy in any oil burning device any
any power plant or car
is fundamentally
uh consuming the carbon capacity of the
oceans and atmosphere well it depends on
when and how many trillions of CO2 get
pumped at the atmosphere there's no
question that at a certain level it will
destroy the Earth or destroy large
portions of the Earth the question is
just what is that level and how soon do
we do we stop pumping vast quantities of
CO2 into the atmosphere so so that's and
and what makes it super insane is that
we're going to run out of
oil anyway
like it's not like there's some infinite
oil supply we're gonna run out of it so
we know we have to get to a sustainable
means of
of Transportation
no matter what
so why even run the experiment bad
happening past a certain carbon
concentration in the in the atmosphere
and so there's some uncertain number
where if we put too much carbon in the
atmosphere things overheat oceans warm
up
ice caps melt we have quite a serious
climate risk that we're facing there's
fundamentally a subsidy occurring with
every fossil fuel burning thing power
plants aircraft car frankly even Rockets
I mean Rockets use up you know they burn
they burn fuel but there's just you know
with rockets there's just no other way
to to get to orbit unfortunately so it's
the only way
but with cars there's definitely a
better way with electric cars and to
generate the energy do so with
photovoltaics because we've got a giant
thermonuclear reactor in the sky called
the sun it's great it sort of shows up
every day
very reliable
so if you can generate energy from solar
panels stored with batteries you can
have energy 24 hours a day you know it's
important that we accelerate the
transition to sustainable energy
that's why electric cars it matters
whether electric cars happen sooner or
later
you know we're really playing a crazy
game here with the atmosphere and the
oceans
we are taking vast amounts of carbon
from deep underground but it was neat in
the atmosphere this was crazy
should not do this
it's very dangerous
sustainable energy will happen no matter
what if there was no Tesla never existed
it would have to happen out of necessity
it's total logical if you don't have
sustainable energy it means you have
unsustainable energy eventually you'll
run out the laws of Economics will drive
uh it will drive civilization towards
sustainable energy inevitably people
tend to think like why should electric
vehicles have a subsidy but they're not
taking into account that all fossil fuel
burning Vehicles fundamentally are
subsidized by the cost the environmental
cost to Earth but nobody's paying for it
we are going to pay for it obviously in
the future we will pay for it
[Music]